many have been listed for years now
we're talking about short-term rentals
now officially legal in unincorporated
clark county commissioners unanimously
approving regulations today madison
kimbrough is live near the strip tonight
with what neighborhoods can now expect
madison
this is a big deal for several areas
around town as like you said it's a
unanimous vote by board of commissioners
in favor of the idea but some locals
aren't happy about the new rules
we're making an effort to comply both
with the statute
and to respond to what we're hearing in
the community it's official short-term
rentals are now open for business in
unincorporated areas of clark county the
nevada legislature approved ab
last year which required the county to
adopt and enforce an ordinance that
would regulate these rentals and even
with it being a unanimous vote by county
commissioners local rental hosts and
residents still not pleased with the new
guidelines this ordinance if it's passed
as written
is going to cause you more problems than
you have right now it's not going to
help the neighborhoods they'll be
further disrupted it's not going to help
the resorts and as for some of those
guidelines no more than 10 people are
allowed in each rental properties must
also be at least 2500 feet away from a
casino resort and there must be at least
a thousand feet between properties local
short-term rental host beau theodore has
a few rentals in unincorporated clark
county but doesn't agree with how the
county is going about the process
unfortunately
this one percent rule
and the other rules that they have set
up for signing up
uh just don't make a lot of sense i have
two rentals as a matter of fact in the
same
development that are 700 feet apart
one's on one street one's on a
completely different street on a
cul-de-sac
and that thousand-foot rule would
disqualify those so
that doesn't work for me
short-term rental company airbnb issuing
this statement saying in part that with
these new rules it will take money out
of the pockets of nevada residents and
the local tourism economy also adding
that now is the time for the tourism
sector to work together to bolster clark
county's economy and hospitality
industries no word on what these changes
mean for current rental properties that
have been operating thus far illegally
reporting live near the strip tonight
madison kimbrough live local now